you cannot go up here to go in the cache
this way or this way same way you guys
gonna get up to the castle
yeah sure good for me yeah for up from
don't want to see the castle we'll take
it easy Casa sound like oh we're in a
cooler not poor cheated poor cheater
castle up on the top if you can see it
it's right up here see the castle we're
gonna try to get up there few guys a
better look
so you can see here people who haven't
used to have to go through these roads
with horses and carriages and yeah you
know what else our hardest in old time
you know everyday carrying stuff up up
and down up and down this town hall da
cunha in a Portobello Porcha tell okay
so Kula is the castle I'm sorry the
power but the town is called
porch II tell Porsha tells oh cool as
the castle that we're going up to see
look at these unique these uh stone
yeah stone built stair case is very
unique leads up to mustered up they're
gonna go makes a lot
[Music]
I'm like oh nice what are you doing fine
you speak English huh yes a little bit
all right
you can tell you where you work here yes
can you tell us a little bit about this
town history lesson short and not very
well English speak yeah very well
English I understand you but not very
well
whoa I'll do my best to translate
translate yeah you are now in touch the
city or city from fifteen or 16th
century is all City and this first there
was be a Ostrow or hungary empire here
and then was come Othman Lee Osman in
theory and this built here oh the city
you have Madras some tower and this
mosque and other house okay no it's
beautiful thank you thank you very much
famous or you know to Facebook or I
follow me oh yes or no what's your your
name is Sanna Sanna Sanna or means son
of here
thank you nice to meet you too how is
your father I watching on YouTube your
father and your brother and your yeah
yeah he's also there must thank you very
much
so this castles this is still holding up
from that you say cats so he was saying
corner cool cool of course so then you
cannot go up here to go in the castle
this way this way you guys gonna get up
to the castle yes I'm good for me yeah
for from don't wanna see the castle and
she will take a seat a casa oh really
nice made me some really nice people
here and we're about to go here's
another nice mustard here
[Music]
so we just finished making Salah before
not yet Muslims 20 min or even the
Muslims who have been struggling a
little bit with making this a lot you
know the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him he said miffed
ended to say that you know the key the
key to general is prayer you know so
disconnecting from the dunya
surrendering yourself to to your Creator
and just taking that time up you know to
reflect to give thanks it's a wonderful
thing and you and you're missing out
you're far if you haven't got a chance
to really implement that in your life
we're gonna go through this little
corridor up here see where this takes us
[Music]
we come in we take that time out and and
and bilious as a spiritual nourishment
to the salt needs the soul just like the
body he needs food the soul needs that
nourishment you found me some of the
most successful people the billionaires
of the world Oprah Winfrey's you know
the Tony Robbins I talk about a
meditation that one needs to connect
with himself and whatnot but man we
connect with a higher power the almighty
the one who created all this you follow
me we do that five times a day minimum
and then you go back to business you
follow me so that's all we did here we
go right back to bring you some more
from from Bosnia so I'm a great way to
get in to having some good conditioning
yeah
climbing up these steep mountain roads
that people would have to bring their
merchandise up all the way from the
bottom as you can see it's pretty steep
in the road continues to to move upward
it's gonna be pretty tiring where people
were in shape they move they want couch
potatoes
they weren't couch potatoes and a real
fool but look what's infiltrated
everywhere you go look at the cancer
machine if you haven't thrown that out
of your house do it right away
get rid of it it's a cancer juice
diabetes juice coca-cola Pepsi find out
all that stuff
no-good garbage all right so we're
almost at the the top of the Cunha Cunha
cooler cooler castle poor cheeto in
Bosnia another beautiful view
alhamdulillah take a look
[Music]
all right so we made it up to this
castle
how old is this castle around a century
the 15th century and who built it with
the Ottoman the Ottoman Empire built
this castle actually it's a watch tower
there's a watch tower as you see if you
take a look down you see that there's a
road running down towards the adriatic
adriatic coast and towards dubrovnik
which was in that time a merchandise
harbor and all the traffic was in this
connection now towards dubrovnik and
further up to bosnia so the ottomans
they were controlling this point here it
was which tower in many terms both for
the people who are taking their goods
down and also for the military Caicos
what about this one across the weight is
another that the whole the whole city
was surrounded by those walls you see
it's kind of fort around the city and
has preserved quite a lot of the
authentic look some of the buildings are
restored as you see but lots of it as as
you can see is from the time so this is
the inside now of this castle
[Music]
these are the remnants of the people of
the past and they were living at one
point now they're gone
now we're observing what they left
behind pretty soon we'll be leaving it
behind - there's another beautiful you
another beautiful view over here let's
continue on our way up to the top of
this castle alright moving up these
stairs a little bit narrow I'll be real
careful it's another area here Oh think
of it as like a 3/4 flat so we were on
the first floor this is the second and
now you're inside and I'll show you
looking out through what they were able
to look out through check it out really
cool
you're up there is the other part of the
castle let's see if we can get a zooming
over there we made it so this is now the
top of the castle have a look actually
should look out for these old-time films
you see the watchtowers about you're
actually in one
[Music]
she just get out a bit to this point
over there you see the whole village
yeah you guys can say you saw that war
that's dividing the city then over there
you have all the little houses in the
village continuing on through this
little town and Steve so you can see
this still have you know Rock paved
roads and it's kind of still setting
this traditional look
people still occupy these homes right
mm-hmm okay we're still living in here
many of us still still people think
about Nia yeah yeah but uh from Chicago
oh thank you
yes Cargill is it - here at the front of
your thing yeah that's awesome yeah
beautiful country huh really is yeah
whole area
[Music]
thanks to every tribe or a piece of
mercy from resident he or she lives here
salamualikum' carp stick the when we're
in Dubrovnik question from Australia
nice meeting you guys thank you my
friend
thank you very much all right we had a
really great conversation with our
friends from Australia
we just met here in Bosnia and we sat
talked for almost half an hour and we
got to share some beautiful information
they were asking questions and I we get
so I get surprised I mean people is just
just so much false propaganda out there
and people get stuck on this this group
the insane stay so that was one of the
questions that they had and we talked
about that and they heard that Diane and
we we got to go ahead and you you really
got a define you know when people
understand you know what Islam means
submission to the will of the creator
some Muslim one who submits to the will
of God alone you know the basic concepts
you know many of these things we
addressed them but we have to go back to
really what them what the message of
Islam is all about you know connecting
the human being with the one who created
the human being the Creator who sent
messengers out of his love for what to
guide us and when you ask you know
what's my purpose here you turned to God
sincerely alone he's gonna guide you so
really you know so many different things
that people are
are distracted with but we got to ask
answer we got to answer the questions
that they had we had a great
conversation usually this works with
people who travel people who get out of
their towns their homes and they
traveled to earth and then they see may
connect with Muslims and it was a great
opportunity to connect with our friends
from Ozzy and if they tuned in they
could tune in to the D show nice meeting
you guys and we'll continue our journey
here and Bosnia sonic defensive
structures which was built every tribal
a decent mercy from
so this uh mustard was actually part of
it was destroyed and then it was rebuilt
in 2005 but destroyed in August 1993
it says here but it was originally made
in 1562
I didn't get to see the view from where
we were inside when we were inside here
prayed in here when we were inside way
up here now we're on the other side and
we had our nice little conversation with
yes the people we met way up here
somewhere over here
[Music]
clock tower take a look inside stairs
you can go all the way up so that's the
watch tower yeah so that's the watch
tower you guys are looking out for and
I'm here to tell you guys why you so
much do you know the thing is is they
put me on that show a guy a blind person
who started an organization to help
blind people read the Quran in English
English translation of Quran and Braille
and brother Eddie gave me the
opportunity to come and speak about it
not only that yes scholarship all over
the world dropping knowledge on there
and showing you guys that they're
actually real people that you can
approach so that a man come on check out
the channel it's awesome brother
Eddie's awesome and give us a chance
guys watch the Dean show watch the game
show
watch the detail make sure you watch the
dude show watch the Dean show watch the
Dean show watch the Dean show watch the
future
watch the do so